On January 13, 1842 1842, Dr. William Brydon,
who had part of his skull sheared off at the
time, rode an exhausted horse into the British
garrison at Jalalabad, Afghanistan.
When asked where the rest of the army was,
he replied “I am the army”.
In fact, he wasn’t actually the sole survivor,
as he thought, but was pretty close to it.
The few other survivors tended to be certain
high ranking officers and some of their wives
who were captured and held prisoner.
The 4,500 troops (700 British and 3,800 Indian)
were commanded by Major-General William George
Keith Elphinstone.
They were accompanied by about 12,000 camp
followers, made up of various craftsmen; servants;
barbers; blacksmiths; etc., along with many
wives and children of soldiers and the other
camp followers.
Along with leading this small army, Elphinstone
was also noted for being one of the commanders
at the Battle of Waterloo.
This is where his positive accolades end though
as General Elphinstone was generally considered
a poor commander and was even called “the
most incompetent soldier who ever became general”
by one of his fellow Generals (William Nott).
Initially, things went very well for Elphinstone
and his troops stationed in Kabul, Afghanistan.
At first, they numbered 20,000 with another
38,000 in a civilian camp.
The lifestyle in Kabul for them was very luxurious
and peaceful after they initially took over,
despite the justified unrest among the Afghan
people towards their relatively recent British
conquerors.
This peaceful lifestyle was purchased at a
high price by the British government in India,
who paid subsidies to surrounding tribes to
keep them placated.
The lifestyle was so peaceful that most of
the troops were ordered back to India, leaving
just 4,500 in Kabul with about 12,000 civilians
in tow.
Unfortunately for the soldiers, though, it
was eventually decided that the cost of the
subsidies and maintaining the small garrison
in Kabul was too great, so the subsidies stopped.
Shortly thereafter, a group of Afghans murdered
one of the chief British political officers
in Kabul, Alexander Burnes.
Rather than take any action to prevent further
uprising, General Elphinstone didn’t respond
at all to the murder.
Soon, a series of small skirmishes took place,
at which point Elphinstone realized their
peril and called for reinforcements from Kandahar.
Unfortunately, no reinforcements were able
to reach him because of heavy snow in the
passes.
To get around the issue, another high ranking
British official decided to try to negotiate
safe passage to the garrison at Jalalabad
for the soldiers and 12,000 camp followers.
The Afghan rebels, led by Akbar Khan, initially
seemed open to such a treaty and invited the
British to a meeting… where they subsequently
slaughtered the British delegation directly
after the British dismounted their horses.
Once again, rather than respond in any way
to this event, General Elphinstone chose to
do more or less nothing initially.
He followed this move by the genius stroke
of making an agreement with the rebels which
included stipulations that the British soldiers
would hand over much of their gunpowder, muskets,
and heavy artillery before leaving.
In return for giving up much of their ability
to defend themselves to the rebel troops who
would then subsequently be well armed, they
were to be granted safe passage to the garrison
at Jalalabad some 90 miles away.
Naturally, the second the main portion of
Elphinstone’s army and camp followers left
Kabul, they were fired on from the ramparts
of the city, with their rear flank taking
heavy casualties.
Further, those sick and wounded who were left
to follow along as soon as they could were
slaughtered by the Afghans and the former
army encampment was set on fire.
Despite being attacked the second the troops
were out of the city, rather than quicken
the march to the critical pass 10 miles away,
to make sure Afghans didn’t get there first
and setup fortifications, Elphinstone, rather,
ordered a halt after just 6 miles.
The next day, they made it the remaining way
to the pass, but the Afghans had already secured
it, armed of course with the British gunpowder
and weaponry General Elphinstone had given
them a few days before.
By that night, around 2/3 of Elphinstone’s
army lay dead, unable to penetrate the pass.
Finally, Elphinstone and his second in command
voluntarily left their troops and surrendered
themselves (the General later died in captivity
a few months later), though the surviving
troops and followers that weren’t yet captured,
continued on.
Most of the others who chose to surrender,
including women and children, were killed.
The few who might fetch a ransom were simply
taken back to Kabul and held captive.
One group led by Thomas John Anguetil did
manage to soldier on and made it as far as
the small village of Gandamack, less than
a day’s ride from the garrison at Jalalabad.
During their journey from the pass to that
village, the group took heavy casualties as
they went and only about 20 officers and 45
other soldiers made it to Gandamack.
As you might expect from them having made
it this far without breaking, these soldiers
weren’t quite so willing to surrender, even
after they were surrounded and were given
the chance; so the fight continued.
Of those remaining 65 of the once 16,500 strong
group, all but seven were killed at Gandamack.
Six mounted troops manage to flee the scene
after nightfall, with five of them killed
before they reached Jalalabad.
In the end, Dr. William Drydon manage to make
it, being the first and one of the only ones
who managed to do so (a few others managed
to make it back, such as a Greek merchant
and also a “Mr. Baness”, though Baness
died the next day).
By Drydon’s account, he and a Lieutenant
were abandoned by the other officers, the
officers having horses in better condition.
The two then continued on alone before finally
the Lieutenant chose to stop and hide until
nightfall, even though they were just three
miles from the garrison.
Dr. Drydon thought it was better to keep moving,
which he did and arrived at the garrison at
around 1 P.M. on January the 13th.
The Lieutenant never made it.
Interestingly, Brydon’s life was actually
saved by a paper magazine which he had stuffed
in his hat to try to keep his head warm (it
was extremely cold at the time, with heavy
snowfall on the ground).
At a certain point in his trek, an Afghan
soldier swung a sword at him and it struck
the magazine and rather than cleaving his
whole head, the sword simply deflected and
sheared part of Dr. Brydon’s skull.
Still a none -to-pleasant injury, but not
nearly as bad as it could have been.
Obviously the British didn’t take kindly
to this massacre and the rebels in Kabul soon
were the victims of a massacre of their own
when a British army lead by a competent General
this time, William Nott, marched into Kabul
shortly thereafter.
All total around 50 hostages were rescued
after the British army re-took Kabul, nearly
all that was left of the 16,500 people that
had attempted to flee that city.